>> WELCOME BACK.
MORE NOW ON OUR TOP STORY.
PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY
SAYS UKRAINIAN TROOPS ARE
MAKING POWERFUL ADVANCES IN THE
SOUTH.
UKRAINIAN LEADER, SAYS THAT THE
OCCUPATION HAS BEGUN.
DESPITE A SETBACK, THE KREMLIN
IS MOVING FORWARD TO ANNEX FOR
UKRAINIAN REGIONS.
EARLIER TODAY, PRESIDENT
VLADIMIR PUTIN SIGNED INTO LAW
MEASURES DEEMED ILLEGAL UNDER
INTERNATIONAL LAW.
BOUGHT A WHILE RUSSIA SAYS IT
SHOULD BE PART OF THE PROBE
INTO LEAKS IN THE NORTH STREAM
GAS PIPELINE.
SWEDEN HAS BLOCKED OFF THE AREA
AROUND THE PIPELINE PENDING AN
INVESTIGATION.
WE WANT TO WELCOME SWEETENS
PETER HOLT, SWEDEN'S DEFENSE
MINISTER.
AND HE JOINS ME NOW FROM
STOCKHOLM.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US,
MINISTER.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
>> THERE HAS BEEN SO MUCH
SPECULATION ABOUT THESE BLASTS
ON THE PIPELINES THAT RUN FROM
RUSSIA TO GERMANY ANY.
MANY POINT TO SABOTAGE.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THE
LIKELY CAUSE AND THE CULPRIT?
>> THE FIRST OF ALL, WE'VE
HEARD THEY ARE DOING A POLICE
INVESTIGATION.
THE SWEDISH POLICE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT.
THEY ARE DOING IT IN THE AREA.
THIS WILL TAKE SOME TIME BUT
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT THEY
CAN DO THEIR JOB.
THEY ALSO DO THE SAME FROM THE
DANISH SIDE.
WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE AND WE HAVE
NO RESULTS YET.
THEY HAVE TO COME BACK WITH
INFORMATION BUT I THINK IT'S
TIME FOR THAT.
THAT IS THE TOPIC, NUMBER ONE.
TOPIC NUMBER TWO IS THAT FROM
OUR FIRST ANALYSTS IS THAT THIS
IS DONE BY SOMEBODY THAT HAS A
MISSION TO DO SOMETHING THAT WE
SEE THERE MAY BE A
RESPONSIBILITY AND I
UNDERSTAND.
IT IS >> I UNDERSTAND, MINISTER,
THAT SWEDEN HAS SENT A DIVING
VESSEL BUFFALO TO INVESTIGATE.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
HOW LONG IT WILL TAKE.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT YOU CRANE,
ALONG WITH MANY OTHER NATIONS,
IS ALREADY POINTING THE FINGER
AND BLAMING.
RUSSIA TO FIND RUSSIA
RESPONSIBLE, WHAT SORT OF
ACTION ARE YOU WILLING TO TAKE?
>> WE HAVE NOT HAD ANY EVIDENCE
OR PROOF SO WE CAN NOT SAY IT'S
A SPECIFIC NATION.
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO NOW IS TO DO
A GOOD JOB AROUND THIS
INVESTIGATION AND THEN WE HAVE
TO COME BACK.
WE'VE >> SEEN SO MUCH WE HAVE
SEEN SO MUCH GAS BUBBLING IN
THE OCEAN FROM THESE PIPELINES,
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE AND WHEN
WILL THESE LEAKS SEAS?
>> IT'S VERY EARLY TO SAY BUT
IT DOES IMPACT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUESTION.
I THINK THERE ARE STILL SOME
ACTIVITY WITH THESE LEAKS BUT
WE ALSO HAVE NOW STARTED THE
INVESTIGATION AROUND UNDER
SECURITY POLICE.
>> I UNDERSTAND MINISTER THAT
YOU HAVE COME FROM THE SWEDISH
FOREIGN POLICY COMMITTEE
MEETING.
WHAT WAS SAID ABOUT RUSSIA'S
ILLEGAL ANNEXATION OF THOSE
FOUR REGIONS IN UKRAINE AND
WHAT NEW SANCTIONS ARE BEING
CONSIDERED?
>> I THINK THAT THE EUROPEAN
UNION HAS TO DECIDE ABOUT NEW
SANCTIONS.
THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT.
I THINK IN SWEDEN, WE HAVE FULL
SUPPORT FOR NEW SANCTIONS AND
ALSO CONDEMN WHAT THE RUSSIANS
HAVE DONE.
IT'S AGAINST INTERNATIONAL LAW
IN ALL MEANS THAT ESCALATE THE
WAR WHEN THEY ARE DOING IT.
WE CONDEMN WHAT RUSSIA HAS DONE.
IT >> CAN YOU TAKE US THROUGH
THE TALKING LINES, THE AGENDA
FROM THE MEETING HAVE JUST COME
FROM FROM THE SWEDISH FOREIGN
POLICY COMMITTEE MEETING?
>> ONLY THE TOPICS IS THE
ANNEXATION OF CRIMEA.
IT'S ALSO ABOUT THE GAS
PIPELINES AND LEAKS IN THE
ECONOMIC OF DENMARK AND SWEDEN.
THAT IS WHAT WE HAVE DISCUSSED.
SOME OF WHAT WE HAVE DISCUSSED
IS CLASSIFIED AND SOME IS OFTEN
BUT IT'S A GROWTH SUPPORT FOR
CONDEMNING RUSSIA'S ACTIVITIES
IN UKRAINE.
WE WILL SUPPORT ALSO UKRAINE IN
THE FUTURE WITH NEW ELABORATE
WITH WEAPONS SYSTEMS.
>> CAN YOU TELL MORE ABOUT US
THEY WANT TO JOIN NATO AND
SWEDEN WE KNOW HAS DONATED A
NUMBER OF PACKAGES ALREADY TO
UKRAINE.
EITHER ANYMORE ON THE HORIZON?
>> WE HAVE DECIDED ABOUT --
WE HAVE DECIDED SEVEN TIMES
ABOUT SUPPORT INCLUDING
MILITARY MATERIAL TO UKRAINE.
WHEN YOU DIMENSION FROM OUR
SIDE IS THAT WE, TOGETHER,
OTHER COUNTRIES UNDER UK
LEADERSHIP PAID TROOPS TO SERVE
IN THE UKRAINIAN AND FORCES.
WE ARE ALSO INVOLVED IN
INTERNATIONAL DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
PRODUCTION, WEAPONS USED IN
PRODUCTION DIRECTED TO UKRAINE.
WE WILL SEE A LONG TERM SUPPORT
TO UKRAINE AND WE THINK THAT
THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT ALSO TO
SUPPORT IN MANY WAYS.
UKRAINE CAN FEEL THAT THEY HAVE
A REAL SUPPORT AND THAT THEY
CA